gabriel boric a sus 35 años es el
presidente más joven de la historia de
chile
no le tengo miedo a la juventud para
cambiar este país porque también debemos
de la experiencia de quienes lucharon
antes que nosotros un discurso que buscó
a los jóvenes que participaron en el
estallido social de 2019 en rebeldía
contra el conocido como milagro
económico de chile y chile fue la cuna
el neoliberalismo también será tu
compañero
precisamente boris se dio a conocer como
líder estudiantil en 2011 esto le
permitió saltar la política en 2014
cuando fue escogido diputado de
magallanes la zona más austral y
olvidada de chile de donde es oriundo
su partido convergencia social forma
parte de la coalición frente amplio
junto al partido comunista se convierte
ahora en el presidente más a la
izquierda en chile desde salvador
allende derrocado por un golpe de estado
en 1973
moritz buscará enterrar a la dictadura
militar de augusto pinochet y su
constitución de 1980 representando a una
nueva generación que ha dejado atrás la
histórica centroizquierda de la
concertación e incluso su última
presidenta michelle bachelet pidió votar
por boris
no da lo mismo entonces por qué
candidato se vota por eso por gabriel
buenas una búsqueda del centro que se
sumó a sus críticas a los gobiernos de
venezuela y nicaragua pero desde la
oposición no se fían y condenan su
reunión en españa con uno de los
asesinos del diputado derechista jaime
guzmán
moritz promete diálogo y recuerda el 15
de noviembre de 2019 cuando fue artífice
del acuerdo que derivó en el actual
proceso constituyente esto le valió
críticas internas en su coalición
mientras sin corbata y remangado ha
logrado ser el presidente de la nueva
constitución